so today uh i wanted to discuss with you
or meet with you all uh to know you
better and also to give you the right
kind of resources that would be relevant
to all of you
so based on your expectation and
the information that you have got to
join this meeting uh we shared this poll
so that we can understand that where
your interest lies and then we can help
you guide through this research
fellowship program so i have
a really
long experience working in this field of
uh computational biology i did my phd
and before that i did my master's in
bioinformatics and uh i was able to work
on several of these projects and
completing many of these and publishing
a lot of them so um i think in here as a
mentor uh one of my our responsibility
is to complete those analysis that we
plan that we work through so you saw the
structure uh in this meeting i wanted to
uh quickly take you through a couple of
things
before we all uh move to the very
excitement
expectations where we have the research
fellow student research fellows uh who
would be presenting their work
quickly
as we are running out of time so uh
before we move there i just wanted to
ask everyone do you have these similar
questions in your mind if so then we
will be happy to answer some of these
questions in the chat and help you
understand how this works so i'll read
them out the questions that we have
that we get from the students all the
time so
the entire research fellowship program
can this program be a requirement for
the university internship
uh yes and i'll show you quickly the
structure what is the difference between
three months and six-month program
so in a three-month program we cover
most of the things that you that you saw
in this presentation including how to
work on a project and to complete a
project but within a six months time
because uh these projects they vary uh a
lot based on the research question they
vary a lot based on the group that is
working that it is working on
it also varies
based on the amount of time that you are
giving to this research relationship
program so based on all the time
requirements and the flexibility that we
offer this could be done in three months
six months and we usually have
this option given to students when they
have exams to pause the research
research fellowship and then start it
again after their examination and our
about the hourly commitment so how many
hours hours commitment does the research
fellowship program requires so it's
again a question that kind of
is personalized
it depends on the number of hours that
is available for the student and the
mentor but usually the way it works is
that initially when you're going through
the coursework and understanding that
how these all of these components work
uh you have to give at least uh you know
three to four hours a day to understand
how uh how the coursework is aligned
with the tbi info platform and the
example projects and that everyone has
to learn to be able to work on a
research project followed by that it is
more about you know finding the right
question doing the analysis where the
time can be managed according to your
own um
schedule so what are the mental
mentorship options uh so we have a group
of mentors from uh industry from
academia from our own in our own company
um that includes uh all of us who are
present in this meeting so
based on the question we can assign or
we can suggest mentors who are an expert
in this specific field
uh okay the next question can we choose
any topic uh yes
that requires you to go through the
course work and understand what are the
different areas of research uh where
what kind of research is ongoing and if
you can find specific publications and
prepare the project form that we
discussed then you can work on a topic
provided there is enough data for you to
work on
so the next question uh can we
participate in group projects yes uh
there's a great opportunity as we're
collaborating with uh with industry as
we're collaborating with academia
research labs there are many projects
that we are working on which are cutting
edge which requires uh a lot of
workflows where you can participate and
work on those group projects they are
also part of the research fellowship
program but it is recommended that we
provide that sort of
opportunities for people who have
already at least completed one project
uh the next question can we publish our
project one of the major uh goal of this
research fellowship program is to be
able to highlight this research that you
have done in your own profile so
publishing your project gives you that
tremendous amount of you know exposure
and
makes you a part of the scientific
community so yes
and then the next question the eighth
question is about pricing payment option
and scholarship so this research
fellowship program includes several of
these resources that we talked about
that includes the example projects that
includes the basic beginner coursework
that includes the p by info platform
server access that includes the access
to mentors group sessions and this is an
entire process that develops your
project so yes uh there is some pricing
options that are available for anyone to
join the research fellowship program but
it is also advised as advisable to
understand this that
me all of this payment is going for the
resources that you have been provided
with
help students from low income countries
for students who have financial
difficulties in doing a program we
provide scholarships from our end and
also from universities whom we have
collaborated and offering these programs
uh in uh together
so uh furthermore if you have any more
questions
i will request all of you to put it in
the chat box and our team will be happy
to assist you and we will be reaching
out to you specifically to answer any
questions that you have
about the specific topics that we
discussed and also these questions that
we have put together
so um now moving on i just wanted to um
[Music]
like discuss about our university
collaborations and how all of these
resources are helping a university
develop student capacity as well as
develop research projects as well as
develop grants and publication
so um i mean uh to discuss about we have
already discussed about these all of
these uh topics in detail so we have
beginner coursework for students who are
really new to this field who would want
to start their journey and would want to
work on a project eventually so we have
a detailed coursework that enables
anyone so most of our students who are
coming from the background which is
mostly biotechnology
microbiology even computer science so
this coursework is built for biologists
it's meant for biologists to learn data
science to learn biomedical data science
to learn bioinformatics and apply to a
real project so there is a beginner
coursework which is very detailed for
anyone without a background to learn and
apply this
then we have these specific coursework
on multi-omics fields big data
bioinformatics where you will learn that
how do you see these data how do you
visualize such a big amount of data and
make meaningful information get
meaningful information from there by
using several of these tools including
the t by info multi-omics platform that
helps again the beginners and anyone to
get that infrastructure run experiments
analyze data
from a very easy to use point-and-click
system the the one of the purpose of
making this as a simple system is that
the logic of analysis the
the meaning of the research
can be understood and that is one of the
main focus of this research fellowship
training this research fellowship
program and we are really
happy with the outcomes that students
are getting from this because their
understanding why they're doing it and
then they are performing the research so
followed by that we have this difference
very specialization the kind of research
that
excites everyone that we have in this
omics logic research where you can work
on specialization fields such as space
omegas and then you can work on very
difficult problems such as cancer and
for all of for all of this i mean after
doing the basic training the research
training you start you doing your
exploratory analysis and do your
literature review and followed by that
data analysis and interpretation so
that's the training part and that is
well uh discussed in this meeting and i
hope that it's kind of clear to all of
you if not we will be again sharing with
you
uh the resources that will help you
understand
so uh the technical training we
discussed this um there are several of
these uh
data types that we are using patient for
clinical data
animal models where these experiments
have been tested many of the drugs have
been tested which starts from a cell
line experiments uh eventually and then
we understand analyze processes and
annotate and integrate this sort of data
for many purposes such as drug discovery
which is a very important thing that you
learned from this precision medicine
talk today and by the help of uh tools
such as the tbi info platform and coding
languages such as python and r we have
been able to do downstream analysis
which is really good for
all of that uh things that we want to
highlight like a poster presentation
like like the presentation that you do
for your university or for a
grant so that's the technical training
part followed by that we have the
introductory coursework then the example
projects that you have seen then we have
the specialization training and then you
work on a research projects with very
defined steps so because of all of this
i mean that's the reason we have been
able to do it
challenging so all of this is well
structured there is a help in within
every step there is support within every
step for students from different
background from different educational
and geographical location
now
as you have learned about the entire
process like this entire process of
understanding and writing
all of this is also supported by uh
faculty projects so once you have gone
through these steps uh we align your
interest with the faculty project with
the partner university that we have and
we have faculty who have proposed
projects whom we are working with and
are
more uh you know focused towards the
translational outcome more focused about
you know getting publications and
getting that recognition so these are
some of the opportunities that we
provide to students to work with faculty
who have these defined projects and uh
who can help further giving you the
right kind of feedback to develop your
project
so
that is what i wanted to show you all in
uh in this short presentation that i
have put together but uh before i leave
uh and pass it through this to sri gauri
to help students come and discuss about
their research i wanted to tell you
about couple of opportunities
so we have campus ambassador
opportunities um and also the
scholarship opportunities and internship
opportunities these are for students who
are well versed with omits logic and
would want to represent omics logic in
their campuses or in would want to work
with us uh in our within our team to
help
awareness of bioinformatics so these are
some of the opportunities again for the
participants who are in the us and who
are in louisiana area and also who are
those who are connected with the nappy
network
we are offering many of these training
programs starting from june
uh to this uh to the students who will
be pre-registering and we'll be reaching
out to help them register for these
fully
sponsored programs
where the students are studying in this
universities and also we are providing
50 and above scholarships for students
who are coming from outside and who want
to be a part of these programs these
training programs which is more of to
you know give you an understanding of
how the different data types can be
analyzed for a specific specialization
and also like the research fellowship
program is being offered in the us and
if you are in the u.s you can
avail that program if you are in india
and if you are in
africa you can avail the program and
details that we are sharing with you in
this meeting so that's about it and um i
i would like to pass this back to shri
to invite quickly students and we have a
very less time like we have only 14
minutes left in this meeting so we will
just conclude accordingly and have a few
presentations and rest we'll be able to
send you
through video recording thank you so
much